all right guys we're playing white
against
joe john tara 34. hopefully we get a
chance to play another danish
let's see d4 come on take my pawn
hopefully we get
take my
[Music]
no knight c6 see that they're not
playing they're not going for the danish
now knight c6
is fine i mean that's not a terrible
move and i know that
for a lot of beginners there is a
general temptation
to do two things the first is to trade
when traits are possible thank you
beastmaster the second is to push funds
the move d5 is super tempting here it
grabs a lot of space
but it's actually not as good as it
looks because it closes down the center
i'll explain what that means after the
game one second
like what does that mean definitionally
but it basically means there's a lot of
pawns that are clogging up the center
and with the white pieces muff can see
because he's thinking of the prime what
we want to try to do
is open the center up as much as
possible in the center is open
there are more opportunities to attack
there's more opportunities for tactics
that shouldn't be
surprising so we're just going to go
ahead and take the pawn
now um there's a couple of options
some of you might be thinking f4 is very
tempting to chase away the knight
what would be the drawback of the move
f4 who can explain to me conceptually
because doesn't isn't it good to chase
away the knight and grab space in the
center
it opens up the king right it allows
these options like when h4 f4 is not a
bad move it
also makes it harder for us to develop
this bishop actively
so instead of playing a move like this
let's just develop our pieces what does
that mean what should we do here
and it's true that this knight on e5 is
a good knight it's centralized
so what can we do about it
so we can play knight c3 and i would
start by playing knight c3
i would see what he does and then either
go knight f3 because we're fine with the
trade
or maybe go bishop f4 to chase them
right see that's what it means to
develop flexibly
we're waiting for him to show how he
wants to position okay that tells us a
lot
that's a pretty passive move now he
can't develop his bishop
and now um we can already develop a
general plan of action
okay
so we can play that f3 and that's a
perfectly good move
what other scheme of development can you
guys propose
so and i'm looking in particular for
like a set of moves here
that have an ultimate nice potato for
president you're the man
so you already need to start thinking
about which way we want to castle
and because he's so passive because
trying to play aggressively with white
we're often going to be castling
alongside castling long which is as i'll
explain more risky generally than
castling sure because the king is
less protected but it's also more
conducive to attacking
for for several reasons one of which is
that black will usually castle short
and then you'll basically have carte
blanche to just push all of your puns
without fear that your king is going to
get more and more weak
so let's do that let's play bishop out
to e3 then we're gonna play queen d2
we're just going to castle long
we're going to see what happens so
h okay so bishop g4 is a very common
slight mistake because it allows us now
to secure
our e4 pawn with tempo what am i talking
about here z term thank you
yeah and f3 is a move that i know will
cause some confusion
because didn't i just say that pushing
the f bond causes weakness while things
have changed
and because we are so close to castling
long this move turns
from a liability into a huge asset
because not only does it cover the e4
pawn building upon chain but potentially
it helps prepare g4 which is a way that
we could
start attacking on the kingston okay so
c5 is a bad move
for many reasons one of which is that
he's not developing a piece
another reason you know shades of the
last game is that the d5 square is now
very juicy outpost for the night
but let's not do anything until we've
castled
castling is going to make make it much
easier
uh to operate we because we won't have
to worry about our king
now let's operate what kinds of moves
come to mind here
there's many possibilities now if we
were to play this by the book
if we were to do what i had
set out to do when i castled long we
would not give this check
we would actually go g4 let's attack on
the king side using our pawns
let's chase his pieces away watch what
happens
watch what happens g4 okay
well that was pretty quick uh benefit it
takes g4
now and only now we've won a piece
time to time for us to develop our
bishop
now he's got to cover with his knight if
he knows what's good oh
okay this is going to get juicy guys
what should we do
this is going to get juicy
boom occupying the outpost
okay so this is where things get
confusing for a lot of players
because a lot of people i know so look
at this position where's the mate man i
can't find the mate maybe i give a check
on f4 with the knight
it just steps back to you so i mean you
know what do i do here
what you need to do is you need to think
backward you need to reverse engineer
the mating position and think about it
this way the king has no squares you
would agree with me on that bishop
covers this
knight covers this so the bishop and the
knight are essential
to the mating mechanism we don't want to
move either of these pieces
instead you want to try to involve a
third piece if you involve a third piece
and you give a check from anywhere it's
going to be made
as long as it doesn't interfere with
these two pieces
in good piece to involve in this event
is a
screwdriver piece like a knight a piece
that can sort of wiggle in around the
edges
and deliver quick checks and so we're
going to go oh knight h3 he pre-moves
knight takes e3
and that knight is heading to f4 that is
checkmate
now black could have stopped this
actually with a particularly nice
defensive move we would have still been
completely winning
let's analyze um
so knight c6 is our opponent's move now
this transposes into what's called the
nimzovich defense
save that name i've talked about him in
the five minute speed run aaron
nimsovich
he's occupying prime position our
dramatis personae he's
pretty significant uh character in the
development of chess this is called the
nimzovich defense
it's pretty obscure but it's not that
bad and we basically transpose now i
could go knight f3
this would be the scotch um the scotch
usually arises
via this move motor so it's a
transposition
in another word you'll often hear gm's
throw around transposition that just
means a position
that has been reached transposition
right it's
it's it's been reached through a
different move order
um so this position can be reached
through the move whether we reached it
right here here or it can be reached
through the movement or knight f3 knight
c6 and d4
but trans to transpose means to reach a
position
through a different move order does that
make sense
um so just to clear up any confusion not
very good at defining terms but
if it's confusing um just please
don't hesitate to ask me to clarify now
the scotch
is a very good opening it's an a tier
opening
i played the scotch all the way until i
was about 1700 it is one of the openings
that i recommend
for players in the 13 1400 range um
because it it forces you to get a good
sense of how to develop your pieces
all right so this move d5
is very tempting but it closes down the
center
and even though it forces black to
retreat the bottom line is that when the
center is closed
and the center is clogged up that's not
good or bad inherently but it is
much harder to attack and that should
just make sense on its face you don't
need to know anything about chess
to understand the concept that when when
the area is wide open
you can involve more pieces into that
area it's not occupied by pawns right
so that's why we open up the center and
we develop our knight
and now we play bishop e3 so we're
preparing to castle king's
queen side there's many ways to play
this position and bishop g4
is is a classic classic mistake because
black sees that he's attacking our queen
i think well that's a good square for
the bishop
but if you look one step further we go
f3 and move that we wanted to play
anyway and now we play with tempo
bishop h5 queen d2 we castle and now the
move g4
so bishop b5 check is not quite as good
as it looks why not what should black do
in the event of bishop e5 by the way
this is what he should have done here as
well
it's just that he's already given up a
piece
so he definitely shouldn't bring the
king up remember that there are three
ways to deal with the check
hammer this into your mind you can take
the piece that's delivering the check
sometimes not here you can move your
king or you can block the check and that
third thing is what's most often missed
move like knight c6 easy to miss
is a lot of people are conditioned to
move the king when you're in check
okay so those checklists that checklist
can really help you
uh if you're desperate um i know it
sounds simple
so we had a question about why i played
bishop b3 not bishop f4
and bishop f4 would be fine although i'm
not really threatening to take the
knight i'm just sort of staring at a
knight that is defended um and i'm i'm
clogging up the f pawns path maybe later
i want to play f4
and i want to reserve that right if that
makes sense the checklist oh that was an
unintentional one okay
so we go g4 now this
is what i would call a pawn storm no
what i would call it what's called a
pawn storm pawn storm is the sustained
movement of ponds oh my god somebody
just gave me a diamond membership gift
my alchemist thank you that's that's a
very sweet
um i really really appreciate it so i
guess we're diamond members now yeah
thank you and i'll alert chess.com as to
this account tomorrow
now pawn storms are conducted for
several reasons
okay the classic reason
is to destroy or at least to damage
the pawn cover around your opponent's
king
that is the sort of stereotypical pawn
storm right that often happens in the
sicilian defense let me
just close your eyes first i'm going to
fast forward to a
classic example of a pawn storm
that can be undertaken to destroy
king cover and look at this position
open your eyes
g4 h4 h5
g5 g6 why are you doing all this you
want to destroy the pawn cover so that
when the pieces come into the attack
they do so in a more purposeful manner
right
um but that's not the only
motivation behind a pawn stone and the
secondary motivation
we saw that here is to use the pawns to
just trample over our opponent's pieces
pawns are so dangerous
because whenever they attack a piece the
piece must respond to it
right pawns are in being as philidor
said they're the soul of the game
and why did he say that because although
they're numerically speaking the least
valuable piece
uh they're they're the piece capable of
delivering the sort of most
damage for move right because uh of
the way the way in which pieces must
respond to them thank you ritz plays
so what we would do here is play g5
attack the knight
how would you continue this pawn storm
bingo f4 look at
what the pawns are doing you've
literally kicked away all of black's
pieces
you've clamped down on the position and
you have an amazing position your vision
black doesn't lose any pieces
white is in tremendous position here
yeah and you need to be very you do need
to be very thoughtful as to how you
structure a pawn storm because pawns
uh can can be owned by pieces sometimes
and there's concept like blockade um or
counter sacrifice that can allow you to
deal with upon
storm successfully and we'll delve into
that later uh but i just wanted to
introduce that concept here
so it takes takes he decided to give up
a piece for two puns
which is of course not betrayed and king
e7 is the decisive mistake
knight c6 keeps the game alive still
very very bad
e7 check and now knight h3 target
positions
let's deconstruct this let's reverse
engineer this well the king is out of
squares which means that if we give the
king any check
it's probably going to be made um how
last question how can black defend
against this who can find
the best way to prolong the game defend
against knight f4 mate
now when you're thinking about defending
against me
another main checklist you should we
call it a mate list you can
again capture the piece that is
threatening the checkmate
not here the knight is not capturable
you can defend
the square on which they may occur so
the knight g6 is possible here but now
knight g5 is crushing or
you can carve out a pathway for the king
and that is what you can do by playing
f6 carving out the f7 pathway
still completely losing we're attacking
we're crushing we can chase this knight
away
but the game goes on for a couple more
moves okay or deliver a check of your
own est equal or stronger threat
yeah knight f3 is also possible here but
the problem is you'll end up going to e5
and
you're not going to survive for very
long for very much longer here
so so that's uh that's the game now
there's a lot more to talk about here
and one of the hardest things about
structuring this speedrun given that
we're talking a lot more during the game
is going to be not to like over overly
explain certain concepts because i want
to save stuff
for when we're at a higher rating when
we're at a higher rating i'll talk about
those concepts
at a higher level so hopefully i'm doing
a halfway decent job of that
these were the first three games of the
speedrun guys and uh
i have pronounced the speedrun begun
we're 578 we started
at 411 so we've gained quite a bit of
rating but that's by design
we don't want to get stuck for too long
on the total beginner level
so we're going to have a couple more
games before we reach eight nine hundred
and uh we're gonna go probably all the
way up to 2200 for the ten minute speed
run
so i hope you guys enjoyed a little bit
tired it's late in the night so
you know i'll be a little bit higher
energy for the future speedrun editions
um and i always get this unsatisfied
feeling okay
i didn't talk about this i didn't
structure this correctly
i know you guys appreciate it i
appreciate it you appreciate it
and i'll keep trying to be better so
this is part two of the speed run ten
minute speed run it's going to youtube
and uh just to recap we're playing
aggressively with white positionally
with black
we are trying to cover some of the
concepts that i didn't talk about
in good enough detail in the first speed
run
as well as open up new ways of thinking
and new concepts
if i'm being too repetitive if you feel
that i'm just repeating what i said in
the first unit please please please let
me know about that
and be direct i might be offended thank
you guys
all right let's call it a night 5 a.m
it is time for me to hit the sack
[Music]
you